YOU GOT SOME PEOPLE STANDING
BEHIND YOU.
SAY HI FOR ME.
AFTER TEXAS DEMOCRATS PACKED
ONTO PRIVATE JET, PROUDLY
POSING WITHOUT MASKS, FLYING TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO AVOID
VOTING ON TEXAS' ELECTION
INTEGRITY BILL LAST WEEK.
TWO OF THE FIRST THREE TEXAS
LAWMAKERS WHO TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVID MET WITH
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE PHOTO.
AND THERE ARE ALWAYS RECEIPTS
THESE DAYS, RIGHT?
THE CREW ALSO MET WITH OTHER
DEMOCRATS WHO APPLAUDED THEIR
MOVE, INCLUDING NEW YORK
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND AND
SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER, AND APPEARED
AROUND CAPITOL HILL MOSTLY
NOT WEARING MASKS.
AGAIN, WE DON'T KNOW THE
VACCINATION DETAILS ON THESE
PEOPLE, BUT WE DO KNOW THAT MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE NUMBER HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID.
NOW, JUST IMAGINE.
AND IMAGINATION EXPERIMENT HERE.
THE MEDIA REACTION AND WHAT IT
WOULD BE IF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
SCENARIO WHERE REPUBLICANS.
PETE HEGSETH?
>> Pete: OH, HARRIS, THAT'S
THE RIGHT PLACE TO START.
THERE ARE SOME MOMENTS WHEN THAT
IS EXACTLY THE WAY YOU NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IT TO UNDERSTAND NOT
JUST THE HYPOCRISY, THIS IS NOT
HYPOCRISY, THIS IS THE
HOME TEAM.
THIS IS THE MEDIA WHICH HAS BEEN
COVID OBSESSED FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF BEFORE THEY WERE, OF
COURSE, TRUMP OBSESSED
COMPLETELY.
THEY ARE NOW HAPPY TO COMPLETELY
IGNORE THIS EXAMPLE OF A
BLATANT -- WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
CALL IT?
A SUPER SPREADER EVENT?
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR TEAM.
SO THEY IGNORE IT.
AS A RESULT, WE HAVE TO LEARN
ABOUT THE TRICKLE OUT AND WE ARE
THE ONLY PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE CAME ON THE WAY
ON THE COUNTRY ACROSS A PRIVATE
JET WITHOUT MASKS.
ULTIMATELY THEY ARE CONFIRMING
THE POINT MANY OF US ARE TRYING
TO MAKE, WHICH IS THAT IF YOU
HAVE THE VACCINE, LIFE SHOULD GO
BACK TO NORMAL.
YET THEY ARE TRYING TO TREAT IT
THAT WAY PUBLICLY, BUT PRIVATELY
THEY ARE REASSERTING MASK
MANDATES AND TELLING US THAT THE
DELTA VARIANT MAY ACTUALLY MEAN
WE HAVE TO ROLL BACKWARDS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF SIDES TO
THIS STORY, BUT THE REPUBLICAN
COMPARISON IS SPOT ON, HARRIS.
>> Harris: PETE, THE FIRST
DAY -- KAYLEIGH, REMEMBER WHEN
WE WERE ON THE CASH TOGETHER IN
STUDIO?
I SAID TO YOU, IF THEY ARE ALL
VACCINATED, THIS WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS POSTER FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE TO USE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WEARING MASKS.
NOW SUDDENLY CRICKETS, BECAUSE
WE AREN'T GETTING THE QUESTION
ASKED.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE WERE VACCINATED.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE
CONFIGURATION WAS, BUT COVID IS
SPREADING.
IT'S NOT QUITE A SUPER SPREADER
YET BUT THE NUMBERS ARE GROWING
MORE THAN DOUBLE IN THE LAST DAY
OR SO.
>> Kayleigh:
"THE NEW YORK POST" EDITORIAL
BOARD WONDERED, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF THESE WERE REPUBLICANS
ON THE PLANE THAT HAD SPREAD
CORONAVIRUS?
FIVE PEOPLE TESTING POSITIVE.
GUESS WHAT?
WE DON'T HAVE TO WONDER, BECAUSE
WE HAVE A PRETTY CLEAR PARALLEL
EXAMPLE HERE.
WHEN I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TESTED POSITIVE.
HOPE HICKS, MYSELF, AND MANY
OTHERS.
VACCINES WEREN'T AVAILABLE AT
THE TIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE HEADLINES
WHERE?
VANITY FAIR, "COVID INFESTED
TRUMP RAMPS UP THE CHAOS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE CESSPOOL."
THEY WENT NUTS.
I HAD REPORTERS CALLING MY PHONE
WITH INFORMATION THAT HAD LEAKED
ABOUT YOUNG STAFFERS OF MINE,
KIDS JUST OUT OF COLLEGE.
I HAD REASON TO BELIEVE
SO-AND-SO TESTED POSITIVE, THEIR
PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION.
OF COURSE THERE WHERE THE
SEATING CHARTS FROM THE
AMY CONEY BARRETT CONFIRMATION
EVENT.
IT WAS BREATHLESS NEGATIVE
COVERAGE.
BUT HERE THEY GO AWAY UNSCATHED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THAT BEAUTIFUL
LITTLE D ON THE END OF THEIR
NAME, AND THAT STANDS FOR
DEMOCRAT.
STEEL AND LET'S GIVE
LESLIE MARSHALL A CHANCE TO
REBUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS HERE
IF SHE SO CHOOSES.
LESLIE?
>> Leslie: I HAVE A D AT THE
END OF MY NAME AND IT WAS
IRRESPONSIBLE.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE A D OR
R, WHATEVER YOUR INITIAL IS.
THIS IS WHY, HARRIS, THIS IS WHY
PEOPLE HAVE THE BELIEF -- AND I
SEE IT OUT THERE IN
SOCIAL MEDIA, AVON HEAR IT,
PEOPLE THAT CALL INTO MY RADIO
SHOW.
THERE IS A BELIEF THAT IF YOU
ARE VACCINATED YOU ARE IMMUNE
FROM GETTING COVID.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
WHAT YOU ARE IMMUNE FROM IS
BEING ON A VENTILATOR OR BEING
IN THE ICU, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE SEE WITH THE UNVACCINATED
RIGHT NOW.
THIS WAS IRRESPONSIBLE, EVEN IF
YOU ARE VACCINATED YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO STILL BE WEARING A
MASK, ESPECIALLY IN SMALL
SPACES.
THEY WERE ON THAT PLANE.
IF ANYTHING, THIS JUST SHOWS YOU
NEED TO BE VACCINATED, BECAUSE
I'M NOT HEARING ABOUT ANY OF
THEM ON A VENTILATOR IN THE ICU,
AND WE ARE SEEING ALARMING
NUMBERS AND SOME OF OUR STATES,
WHETHER IT'S CHILDREN OR PEOPLE
30-55 YEARS OF AGE NOW, BECAUSE
WE KNOW THIS DELTA VARIANT IS
STICKIER, THAT'S WHAT SCIENTISTS
AND DOCTORS ARE SAYING.
THIS WAS CLEARLY IRRESPONSIBLE,
IT WAS WRONG TO DO, AND I DON'T
CARE IF WE TAKE THE MASK OUT FOR
A MOMENT FOR A PHOTO OP, BUT
STILL THEY ARE IN A SMALL SPACE,
THEY ARE TRAVELING, THEY KNOW
BETTER.
THEY NEED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
>> Harris: LESLIE, IF THIS WAS
FOR A PHOTO OP, THEN I SHOULD
NEVER HAVE SEEN PICTURES OF A
WOMAN'S UNDERWEAR AMONG THOSE
RUNAWAY DEMOCRATS.
IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE GOTTEN TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY WERE
BRAGGING ABOUT BEING RUNAWAY
TEXAS DEMOCRATS BY CALLING
THEMSELVES THAT, BOASTING ABOUT
THIS POLITICAL POINT.
IF WE STEP AWAY FROM COVID FOR A
MINUTE, WE CANNOT UNFORTUNATELY
RUNAWAY FROM WHAT WE SAW INSIDE
THAT WOMAN'S HOTEL ROOM, BECAUSE
SHE WANTS TO SAY SHE IS
SACRIFICING.
EMILY?
>> Emily: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT, HARRIS.
JUST TO BUILD ON PETE'S POINTS
THAT WERE SO TRUE, COVID HAS
BEEN THE SUN AROUND WHICH THE
MEDIA AND ADMINISTRATION HAS
ORBITED THE LAST YEAR.
IT'S THE REASON OUR INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTIES WERE SUSPENDED.
THE REASON WHY THE BORDERS WERE
OPENED, THE REASON WHY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STILL
MAINTAINS MASK MANDATES ARE AT
AIRPORTS AND EVERY SINGLE
FEDERAL BUILDING.
IT'S THE REASON BEHIND LITERALLY
EVERY DECISION.
ACCORDING TO THEM, FOR SPENDING
WITHHOLDING AND MORE SPENDING OF
MONEY AND SUSPENDING OF RATES.
THE FACT THAT THIS STUNT NOW, IN
SUCH A DRAMATIC SELF
MANUFACTURED WAY, LIKENING
THEMSELVES TO SELMA AND SUFFRAGE
AND OTHER POINTS OF HISTORY IN
WHICH PEOPLE DIED PROTECTING
WHAT WHERE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
LIBERTIES.
>> Harris: SO OFFENSIVE.
>> Emily: THE FACT THAT THEY
LIKENED THEMSELVES TO THAT,
RATIONALLY EXIST IN THIS PLANE,
AND HAS ZERO CONSEQUENCES FOR
THIS, NO WONDER THE ONLY
INSTITUTION IN WHICH THE
AMERICANS HAVE LESS FAITH IN
THIS COUNTRY OTHER THAN THE
MEDIA IS COMMERCE.
>> Harris: WOW.
PETE, I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOU.
WHO HAS THE POWER NOW AMONG
THOSE TEXAS DEMOCRATS TO SAY
IT'S NOT WORKING OUT, WE NEED TO
TAKE THAT PLAY IN THE REPUBLICAN
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE HAS
STANDING BY, GET ON IT, GO BACK,
AND GET EVERYBODY ON THE RECORD
WITH WHATEVER THEIR VOTES ARE?
TALK ON THE FLOOR IF YOU NEED
TO.
WHO HAS THE POWER TO DO THAT?
WOULD THAT BE LIKE A
CHUCK SCHUMER?
IS THERE ANYONE AMONG THE
DEMOCRATS?
THEY MET WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND SHE LOVED ON THEM FOR THAT.
>> Pete: THAT'S A GOOD POINT,
HARRIS.
I THINK IT IS NATIONAL
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP WHO HAVE
USED THEM AS A STAND, AS
PUPPETS, AS PROPS FROM THE
BEGINNING TO PUSH HR ONE.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP SAYS YOUR STUNT IS
DONE, BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
STUNNED, BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO
LOSE, YOU DON'T HAVE THE VOTES
THAT COULD CALL A SPECIAL
SESSION, THIS IS AT THE
FOOTSTEP OF THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
THAT'S WHERE THE LEADERSHIP IS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
THE STUNT IS OVER, FAILED
MISERABLY, GO BACK HOME AND
VOTE